hello welcome to the debate on Sky News
I'm Martin Stanford here's our take on
the things we've brought together from
America UK and around the world is the
sky falling in on the Republican vote
will old age decide election 2016 Iraq
pleads for more help as Islamic states
advanced appears relentless there we go
that looks good huh that there it's ugly
all the tweets catching up with the
times or an embarrassing old man the
president goes on Twitter in just 18
months the polls will have opened and
closed and elected the 45th US president
but which party will you choose and most
importantly will you still be able to
vote or will you be just too old let's
welcome back our regular guests as usual
Democrat commentator Geoffrey Robinson
is standing by for us in New York and
the conservative commentator Armstrong
Williams is in Washington Jeffrey you've
got plenty of voting years left on you
well I certainly have November of 2016
left I hope and if the Republican Party
is dying off it can't happen too soon
for me I'm strong I guess you feel that
you've got plenty of voting years left
in you too many others like me uh listen
as you discuss the Republican voters
dying off about 2.6 million at vote it
will be dead by the time in the next
election what is neglected is about 2.2
million other people that voted for
President Obama will be dead also senior
citizens vote younger people don't vote
that has always been a remarkable
difference in the elections and so it's
a it's a catch-22 for both parties let's
bring in the man who did the research
shall we damn McGraw is at Politico
magazine and Dan you discovered didn't
you thought a disproportionate number of
Republicans may not be able to vote come
2016 yeah Martin okay what i was looking
at here is that it's
is that everyone agrees that the sort of
GOP Republicans are older and I just
want to get a cut quantify it in subway
and so my take on it was I decided to
look at how many people based on
actuarial tables and exit polling are
voted in 2012 and are not going to vote
in 2016 on account of their being dead
so we found that there's a difference so
Armstrong was a little wrong it was it's
a 2.3 million who voted for Obama in
2012 are going to be dead by 2016 and
2.75 million who voted for Romney in
2012 aren't to be around in 2060 so it's
a difference of 450,000 uh it's it's in
it's significant not so much in the
whole popular vote but in some states
and that will be crucial surely damn
weren't it because the way the state's
go the patterns the states that go from
one side to the other that's likely to
be in play in 2016 oh yeah how it's
working is that it's likely going to be
decided by about seven swing states um
Ohio Florida Virginia are three of them
and all those were closed in 2012 and
our story isn't saying that the
Republican Party is dying that they're
doing this or that we're saying their
voters are older therefore have a
greater chance of being dead and in the
third point is these states are going to
be very close any either party that has
a slight advantage is very important and
in this case what we're saying is is
that if they're starting a kind of
soccer match let's say it would be
before the game starts they're behind by
a goal it doesn't mean they can't win
it's just they got a little more work
they have to do I think it's just
another establishment writer trying to
give the Democratic Party hope that the
Republican Party is dying out and
nothing could be further from the truth
people are going to always die voters
elections are about the candidates who
is on the ticket the field
Republicans are crowded some candidates
and wild horse can emerge there are many
things that impact the elections in onz
speak of Florida and a high hill they
have been in the past two very strong
Republican heart strongholds you have
Republicans that dominate the
legislation and statewide and there are
other elements that play in this
election and obviously dependent on the
candidate a lot of this has to play out
you know here's a right to write this
story to give the Democrats hope but yet
let's run the race and see what exactly
happens when it's all said and done
Jeffrey what's your take on whether the
age of the candidate is a real issue in
any election for instance i'm thinking
if Hillary does get the nomination she
is it towards a senior citizen will she
bring in more elderly voters she'll
certainly bring in the the black vote
the Latino vote and the women's vote
which matters you know you talk about
age Reagan when he ran and I guess in
1980 turned around and said to to his
opponent age will not be an issue in
this campaign I won't hold age against
you and I think he was he was certainly
in his 70s the oldest candidate to date
no I don't think age is going to be an
issue with the candidates I think the
candidates are going to be an issue the
first Republican debate takes place in
August they have 18 numbskulls all on
one stage trying to run for president
with maybe two of them quasi viable
candidates and the rest representing the
clown car brigade what happens in the
states like Florida and Pennsylvania
which will be important and Ohio is you
have Republican legislators trying to
restrict the vote of young people trying
to take away the votes of poor blacks
and this is this is disgusting it is
typical of what the Republicans do
because they are so completely desperate
and when they're facing Hillary I think
there's just no hope whatsoever
hopefully there's no hope I think she's
going to run away with it well we'll
wait and see won't we dad what's your
take on whether the impact of an L more
elderly candidate rather than I don't
know a man or woman in their 40s say
does that skew support does it actually
helped a certain demographic in the
electorate I'm not sure that
that it makes much of a difference and
you know um our story was not about what
candidates run okay our story was about
how many voters vote okay I mean and and
I'm strongly saying that I was writing
this to give hope for all of the
Democrats no I was analyzing how many
people voted for Obama and are going to
be dead in 2016 and how many voted for
Romney um cool how they play this out it
depends on the candidate an old
candidate can appeal to all sorts of
voters etc etc etc but kind of what you
have to realize is is that it is that
the Republicans have box them into a
corner because they're not getting a lot
of the voters who are younger because of
emphasis on some social issues like gay
marriage which caused problems among
people under 30 okay and they're losing
one's at this other end of the scale
because they're dying on so that's the
problem they're facing and there's lots
of ways that you can deal with it so I'm
strong what would you say will be the
strategy if you've got to replenish the
Republican strength in numbers to try
and set this score you know 200 before
the game starts to use our metaphor from
earlier other is of the Republican
machine as the Republican candidates got
to reach out to younger people you know
I want to say something is going to put
Jeffrey into tizzy I love elemental
tizoc so let me just get started the
Republicans have a very legitimate
argument as to what we're seeing in
Baltimore and Ferguson is a failure of
an entitlement state and liberalism or
you have these democratic strongholds
they continue to support delete elite
businesses that go into these push
neighborhoods but they do nothing for
the inner city I think the Republican
Party has a tremendous opportunity
carved deeply into that so-called black
vote in the upcoming election I think
President Obama's foreign policy as
naive as it is and as good well-meaning
he may be it is a failure you look at
Iran you look at Iraq you look at Syria
um you you look at Libya is just a total
face you look well you look at Israel I
think you have legitimate issues to run
on as it relates to the Democratic Party
and what he has produced economy is
still sluggish it is not
improved in any way and most Americans
are not get off if they deal with the
issues of bomber cares of failure if
Clinton is the nominee which I don't
think she will be they have to run the
support President Obama's policies the
past which a bitter dismal failure yeah
but austral my question was what gets
20-somethings what gets Millennials to
the polls actually never Cantonese I
didn't want to bring this up because i
am dr. Ben Carson's business manager for
full disclosure they just had a recent
poll on who's pulling best among
millenniums and it happens to be dr. ben
Carson and Hillary Clinton so the fact
that he is a candidate and a Republican
shows that there's a formula that works
where millenniums can identify with
people who are running on the GOP side
there's a formula you just gotta follow
and build upon it dad well yes I have a
daughter who's in that age group she's
in college okay she's and she's been in
college too long as far as I'm concerned
in the and so in terms of my checkbook
but this is the deal she's in texas okay
her and her friends because I've been
keeping track of them for years they are
pro free market she just sent me a
picture of her firing an ak-47 okay she
likes of free-market economics they they
like entrepreneurial things they like
the government out of their lives when
you talk about but and here's the key
but when you talk about opposing gehrman
gay marriage when you oppose climate
change evolution some of these other
things they are abortion yes they are
out if you're closing abortion clinics
in the state of Texas and you're getting
rid of Planned Parenthood they are out
they aren't even going to consider
listening to you and that's a key issue
here and it goes along with their having
these older folks that are dominating
the party structure in terms of policy
and so forth they're leaving and not by
their own accord but they're not drawing
in these younger voters and part of it
is the social issues they're gonna have
to do with the social issues and the
best thing they can do is to keep their
mouth shut on them because there was a
bucket if I just say this listen I i
just happen to agree with everything
that dan just said believe it i'm not
and
I and many people hung out hope that
that the Republican Party can adjust
they should kick kick their foot out of
the mouth when it comes to these social
issues they should be more sensitive
that society has change without
compromising their values and what they
believe in but I do think that many
people hold out hope that they can
evolve and get the kind of message that
someone like Dan's daughter can resonate
with across the board but that is a
challenge and dad has to be addressed
Jeffrey and it won't be because any
candidate who says i'm in favor of
women's rights i'm in favor of climate
change legislation goes right to the
heart of the opposition to the
republican party they will never ever
ever elect or nominate a candidate who
will side with the real world on those
issues they don't stand a chance with
social issues and they keep bringing up
these social issues like idiots they
think every time they bring it up
they're going to get a different result
and of course that's the definition of
insanity when it doesn't happen dan I
know this is outside your remit for this
particular article but what's your hunch
about the candidates how's it going to
play out over the next year or so well
it's it I'm thinking this is all
elections have a kind of hold your nose
quality I think this is going to be more
of a holds or nose election um I don't
think Hilary gets people excited about
what she is going to do it's kind of
coming down to who's going to be like
less bad and so what kind of what that
means though in terms of the turnout
these kind of hold your nose elections
means you have lower turnout do you need
the ones who are in your core base to
come out who voted for your party in
prior elections and in this case because
of the aging of the Republican Party
their core base is getting smaller so a
low-key of voters that are dying in the
Republican side more so than then of
become Democratic side means in a low
turnout election that that becomes
it kind of larger sort of caveat that
they're gonna have to deal with Dharma
girl Thank You Jeffrey and Armstrong
thank you Thank You Martin a reminder
you can see Sky News debate on apple TV
on roku and on ketchup and of course
find us on the American websites can use
com / us now the advance of Isis appears
relentless Iraq's government has called
for volunteers to fight against Islamic
state and help retake the city of Ramadi
at the same time the UN National
Security Council said it was considering
how best to support local ground forces
or banos Emma Nicholson is in the UK's
government's trade envoy to Iraq she's
also chairman of a mar international
charity foundation which helps people
whose lives have been destroyed by war
and conflict in the Middle East the
situation in Ramadi is pretty depressing
if not disastrous isn't it the situation
in Ramadi is appalling absolutely
appalling there are hardly any words to
describe but they often this support is
going on because it is a repetition of
what I said have done in Mosul and in
the Nineveh plane and recently as
chairman of the Armed our foundation
I've been talking up there with some of
the victims of ISIL this is slavery this
is sexual abuse beyond belief how any of
the girls can survive and of course the
men are marked off and shot and that's
not having any Ramadi it is an
unspeakable situation we all have to get
together to back the government of Iraq
to wipe these dreadful people out why
aren't they being so ineffective you
think in looking after their own turf
this is a civil war and what this is is
the residue and it's a rather large and
horrible residue of what mr. Saddam
Hussein left behind this is a nation
remember that had 30 years of the most
appalling tyranny and said I'm left a
big network of a horrible and a really
wicked people behind not only in Mosul
and those are the people that in a sense
have not been properly brought in and
dealt with but i have to tell you
they're very very tough and unpleasant
people indeed this is a civil war saddam
hussein left behind this is what I'm
turn the UK left behind isn't it we
entered Iraq to rid Iraq of Saddam
Hussein one of the most cruel tyrants in
modern history just as we thought as we
now remember with Belson liberation on
us again it just in the Second World War
and the First World War we all did
exactly the same against the Nazis but
somehow Iraq is a much much tougher
place it is in a far nastier part of the
world it's got all sorts of enemies
around it and to recover Iraq as a
nation state is a really long job and
ISIL is the worst bit of it at the
moment let's bring in Geoffrey Robinson
who's in New York and Armstrong Williams
in Washington Armstrong this is one heck
of a mess do you see a way out once the
administration decided in 2011 that they
were going to draw all troops and not
leave at least 10,000 troops in Iraq
what do you expect and in this little
fake air missile strikes it's just so
ridiculous it's so embarrassing what do
you expect to happen when your when your
strategy is withdrawing troops and using
airstrikes I mean they have left these
people in the most cruel situation
they've ever been in in fact these
people whether you want to admit it or
not we're far better off under Saddam
Hussein's regime this situation I don't
we don't see any skin inside even though
the president admits to his press
secretary it was a colossal mistake this
is a very embarrassing and a terrible
episode in American history and the only
thing you can do you think he's going to
reestablish change the strategy and put
American troops on the ground the
American people don't have a stomach for
but the only thing that you can do and I
know Geoffrey is going to go off the
chain on this you gotta hire empower
special ops to go in there like
mercenaries and fight those in fight
Isis it's the only strategy that can
work it's the only thing that they fear
for those special ops are going on the
ground effect of mercenaries that's the
answers far as I'm concerned Geoffrey
this has happened on President Obama's
watch hasn't it what's happened on
President Obama's watch because he
inherited it from President Bush I mean
the whole the whole idea of going into
Iraq was a was a phony war based on lies
and false information but let's not
refight that I think having him on the
program is
a great boon because she's the real deal
and and she speaks the truth what what
you have to look at however is what the
Iraqis have done the first move by a
thoroughly corrupt araki government that
the Bush administration installed was
getting rid of the full time Iraq army
and those senior officers formed ISIL so
you know that's the origins of that if
you look at what happened in march in
Tikrit they had regular Iraqi soldiers
fighting alongside US air support and
that cleared decree that seemed to work
what the Prime Minister in Iraq has done
now is he's asked for volunteers which
which say that these are mainly Shiites
going into a Sunni dominated on bar
province and trying to clear out ISIL
without US air support this is a recipe
for utter and total disaster now the
other thing about ISIL did I find very
worrying as our reports now coming out
of the Pentagon that they're moving into
Libya it's kind of like a balloon you
know you push the the balloon and the
air just spreads out to someplace else
going into Libya is even more worrying
than what's happening in Iraq because
Libya is only one Mediterranean Sea away
from southern Europe but Emma Nicholson
how do you make the cause of the Iraqi
people who are suffering in the way you
describe matter to a war-weary world and
in particular a war-weary America and a
war-weary Britain the Iraqi people badly
wanted those 10,000 troops to stay
unfortunately else Ardra people wouldn't
allow that to happen and Maliki's
majority was too slender to let him go
it alone but you know this is no way a
blot on America's history rather the
reverse this was a brave attempt to try
to rescue some people who are under the
heel of a dictator this is not just the
Genocide Convention it is the chemical
weapons Geneva Convention of 1929 all
the red lines that are nowadays
considered to be so appalling were more
than breached they were trampled right
over this is a nazi-like situation it
was a good idea to go in what went wrong
if I could put it this way is that the
cruelty inside Iraq was not decimated
was not conquered by the invasion of
Iraq and by the
freedom of Iraq at the beginning of
democracy therefore has been very very
tough indeed this is a harsh and
unyielding environment and it's not this
sunni-shia thing that's much too
simplistic if I could say that it is far
more complex than this far more than
just sunni-shia in fact an Iraq Sunni
and Shia in the same families and so
what Christians and so well other ethnic
minorities but today all of that is
being pushed out by the Mosul monsters
who are following a very narrow branch
of Islam that is coming straight out of
the seventh century funny thing to do
the seventh century with mobile
telephones and tablets isn't it and
Twitter and all the rest of it so it's
complete full returns and if I could ask
you what would you have the president do
what would you have the prime minister
of the UK do because nothing is not an
option is it well first of all I'd like
more troops from Britain there but I'm
not in charge of the Ministry of Defence
and I can't get a bigger investment in
there because I think we can be bear
more helpful than we are and I think
both the Americans and the British and
indeed anyone else who's in there can
all we can do is to support the Iraqi
government and the Iraqi army itself
whether they call themselves militias
whether they call themselves up troops
whether they call themselves volunteers
they have to be organized to do this
because this is their country their
territory and their future we can't walk
in and try and do it again for them and
actually in Ramadi it's got to be the
Sunnis majority who do it it's going to
be horrible meant Nicholson can I just
ask you if we try and put the conflict
to one side which I know is if you like
a ridiculously big if is the country
getting back to this area where your
specialist is trade there's a lot of
natural resources there a lot of very
entrepreneurial people there if the
conflict could be overcome can erupt
rebuild itself through trade first of
all just a job back for a second a very
good political reason why the Allies
didn't go forward to Baghdad as I badly
wished and said in Parliament we should
have done in 1991 and that's because
there wasn't a majority in Congress for
that to happen that this wasn't the
votes and at the end of the day both of
our nation's are true democracy
and that's the sad thing that happened
then I was that Congress and the British
Parliament had been a bit stronger but
yes the solution is that Iraq wants to
stay together in the North the Kurdish
regional government they know now that
they can't go it alone they've had to
turn immediate into America and to Iran
and the same is true of the rest of the
nation so it's got to be a way in which
we can assist those three parts of Iraq
to come together more cleanly but you
know it's got to take some years to get
rid of these monstrous people the
cruelty that is on being uncovered day
by day our teams on the ground in the
armor foundation and the businessman on
the ground as well the cruel tease that
are coming out but you know this great
strength in Iraq the Iraqi people are
very very strong indeed as Joe of the
Iraq Britain Business Council I've just
had a big conference in Baghdad a huge
conference of business people and
another one just a couple of weeks who
are doing their bill planning the next
one here in London in a couple of weeks
time and business is getting on if you
can just look away from Anbar you can
see a huge amount of work with a corm
with ExxonMobil shall be be and everyone
they're going ahead with all of the work
that will enable our Iraq to come
together so I think there is a future
I'm sure there's a future but we
certainly have to help today berenice
Nicholson thank you very much indeed
next president obama is a record breaker
it's official he's joined Twitter rather
embarrassingly six years after coming to
office it took less than five hours for
the official Twitter account of the
president the United States to reach 1
million followers that broke a Guinness
World Record formerly held by the actor
Robert Downey jr. well let's bring in
Geoffrey Robinson in New York and
Armstrong Williams in Washington Jeffrey
how's your twitter follow tally going
well I'm just shy of a million by about
nine hundred and ninety-nine thousand
something like that but I'm getting
there of course he's up i think i just
saw he's up to 5.6 million or something
like that but that's not the
embarrassing thing i mean i eat terrific
that he's on Twitter and wine
not the embarrassing thing is who he
follows and if you look at who he
follows right away from the day one he
started following all of the Chicago
sports teams but he forgot the Chicago
Cubs I mean he's a White Sox fan but he
completely forgot to Chicago Cubs you
can't do that somebody should have said
what about the cubbies I'm strong why do
you think he did this just now you know
he's a lame duck president it some
harmless I know some one asked him can
they do something about his student loan
the president is not going to do direct
messages to anyone is koo I mean he's
within his lunch he's grown up more
followers and Twitter file then the
Prime Minister Cameron has in one year I
mean he's cool he loves celebrities he
loves Hollywood it makes people feel as
though they're connected to him and what
he's doing he's thinking about his
legacy as president united states and
what way to endear yourself by people
thinking you're real coup by handling
your own having your own twitter Carol
twitter is not cool is it i mean in
terms of sheer i mean so last year or is
it the year before and there was
facebook before that I mean if anything
you should be on snapchat should me the
president is using whatever works best
for him you know there was ETO research
and thorough thought that went into this
because he had other handled handles
before that he used that he really did
not really respond to and this is the
first where he said he would have
directly Twitter I'm sure if the
presidents in the bathroom if he's
waiting in line waiting to walk into a
building he can pull out his fall in
Twitter in this coup standing here with
my wife we're getting ready to do
such-and-such it's just ain't cool stuff
and you know what that's the mind of
most Americans that of a seventh grader
that's kind of stuff that the president
will be tweeting they'll understand uh
Jeffrey the next thing of course is
periscope because they're every Twitter
user now is being encouraged to get
their periscope camera out and you know
it's normally something pretty
pedestrian isn't it about some dull
aspect to their life they suddenly want
us to share with do you think he going
to be showing us around the west wing or
something well he does he does selfies
there's some wonderful selfies that he's
done and a bit and have shown up on
Twitter but the best response to brocks
twitter account came from michel
who tweeted him it's about time indeed
so Jeffrey Armstrong great to see you
thanks for being with us today hashtag
that's it for now and that really is it
for now don't forget the debate can be
seen on Sky News on apple TV on roku and
on ketchup and of course at Sky News
calm / us until next time goodbye